hey it's Whitney from new rockstars and
the new d d movie is packed full of
dragons so I have some fun facts about
them for you today first up is my
absolute favorite boy Denver chowd he's
just a big chunker and he's a red dragon
who uses his fire breath to light the
forges and grackle Stone in the
underdark and in return the durigar gave
him a bunch of people treats to eat and
gold and trinkets and stuff like that
but most importantly snacks next up we
have the statue of a copper Dragon which
later comes to life in the movie copper
dragons are incredibly formidable
fighting opponents but they are also
known for being pranksters jokesters and
riddle makers pretty cool third we see
the black dragon record black dragons
are incredibly evil and vile and gross
and they have this black acid breath
that they use to spray all over the
place and get people and lastly new Nerf
gun merch suggests that we might
actually get to see the Gold Dragon
palorandesk in this movie now gold
dragons are usually good on the
alignment scale so that makes me wonder
if we're gonna see a gold dragon help
out our heroes what do you guys think
let me know in the comments